morning routines are one of the most
important things that you can create in
your life and the reason is when you
start the day if you get early momentum
going the rest of the day is often going
to follow in that it's an idea called
entropy everything moves towards chaos
and the only way to combat that is to
put energy into the system you are not
going to wake up and randomly have a
good day you're going to have to
structure your day in a way that sets
you up to overcome all of the entropy
all of that chaos all of the thousand
things going to come at you on a daily
basis that are going to knock you off
course and the easiest way to do that is
to have a routine that you follow every
morning so you don't have to think about
it you don't have to reinvent the wheel
you don't have to wonder or think about
what you should be doing it's just right
there it is baked into the routine by
doing that now you can actually
accomplish the most important things
first the thing to do in your morning
routine well is to optimize for what Tim
Ferriss refers to as the lead Domino
what's the thing that if I did this it's
going to make everything else easier
down the road so number one a morning
routine actually starts the night before
if you want to get plenty of sleep why
because that's going to optimize your
cognition the next thing you want to do
is either meditate or work out typically
I will work out first the reason that I
work out is because it optimizes your
cognition so that everything else is
going to get easier it also dramatically
impacts your energy levels talk about
two things that are incredible lead
dominoes if I'm getting sleep and
optimizing my cognition if I'm working
out and optimizing my cognition and I'm
making sure that I have the energy
levels that I need to get things done
now I'm really making sure that
everything that I do after that is
easier hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn some powerful morning routines
to activate your beast mode
the next thing that I do is meditate why
because it optimizes your cognition you
want to make sure that you're getting
all of your background radiation the
stress the anxiety you want to get that
as close to zero as you can that way you
can think clearly you get into what I
call a calm and creative state so the
areas of your brain that don't often
communicate are able to communicate get
better ideas that way again lead Domino
improving your cognition lowering your
stress levels making sure that you're
centered and that you've got that energy
to move forward then I'm going to go
down my list of important things I make
that list the day before so I know
exactly what I should be doing at any
one time and again it's a lead Domino
strategy what the first thing that I'm
going to do is going to be the thing
that makes everything else on my list
easier I'm going to do everything that I
can do on the most important thing and
by the way they should always be rank
ordered there is no such thing as a tie
there is a number one a number two and
number three and number four so on and
so forth there is not two number ones
there's not two number twos there was a
one two three four five so on and so
forth I do everything that I can do on
number one once that's now where I'm
waiting for something else or you know I
just have to let it bake whatever then
I'm going to move on to number two I'm
gonna do everything I can on number two
then I'm going to move on to number
three do you set your day up like that
and you're not checking your phone and
you're not responding to other people
because that's letting them control your
schedule and what are the odds that
somebody other than you knows better
what you should be doing to make your
goals come true than you the answer
should be zero because if somebody else
knows better than you we already have a
problem it means that somebody else is
paying more attention to your own life
than you are that would be problematic
get that morning routine down get that
momentum going do the lead Domino
strategy make sure you're optimizing for
energy and cognition absolutely critical
routine number two is high five your
heart with Mel Robbins one of the things
that I learned in researching the book
the high five habit which was freaking
news to me Chase but once you have
somebody unpack it you're like oh
well that makes a lot of sense
um it is research from a woman who is at
UCLA for a long time one of the leading
neuroscientists in the world she studies
the brain and what it takes for the
brain to learn to change to create
and one of the things that she
discovered is the connection between
your nervous system and your brain's
ability to function as it's designed
and to just really dumb it down mostly
for myself
um this is how I've boiled down what she
talks about
so your nervous system trumps your brain
and when you are in a state of stress
or anxiety or uncertainty
and your nervous system gets locked into
a fight or flight response which is what
everybody is in there's no way I mean
your wife may not be there because she
is a expert meditation she's a
practitioner so she has uh daily
practices that help her flip off What's
called the sympathetic nervous system
which is your fight or flight anxiety on
edge oh how am I paying the bills what's
happening in politics gas prices are now
crazy when are we getting off Zoom are
the kids going back to school do I have
to wear a mask do I need a booster like
all of that that you're processing that
makes your nervous system fire up like
alarm alarm that's your sympathetic
nervous system
if you don't switch that sucker off and
flip on the other nervous system you got
two nervous systems sympathetic
parasympathetic parasympathetic is your
resting nervous system
it's your grounded calm it's the nervous
system that's in play when you're in
flow being creative
it's what it feels like when you're
grounded in your body and you're okay
and you feel okay and so what I learned
from Dr Judith Willis is that when
you're
sympathetic fight or flight nervous
system
is run in the show your brain doesn't
work properly
because the alarm system takes over and
I can explain this using a very simple
example
if all of a sudden the alarms went off
in the studio that you're in and you
smelled smoke
would you be able to solve a math
problem
no no
of course I'm out I'm out
well that's basically what it's been
like for the last two years
the fire alarms are going off and your
body your nose smells smoke and so your
nervous system flips on an alarm the
reason why it's so hard to focus the
reason why you're exhausted by one
o'clock in the afternoon the reason why
you feel like you're one more thing away
from checking yourself in and needing
help is because your nervous system is
just fried and it's impacting your
ability to think clearly and so there's
a simple trick that you can use and I
know you've talked about the vagus nerve
a lot on your show it's a really
important thing to understand it's a
treasure inside your body the vagus
nerve is a nerve that runs all the way
from you know your seat through every
major organ your vocal cords all the way
up to the top of your head and the vagus
nerve is the on off switch between your
ocean nervous system and you're I got
this nervous system and so a simple
thing that you can do and I want
everybody to do this at the beginning of
their day and the reason why I want you
to do it at the beginning of your day is
because I guarantee you particularly
because you're in business for yourself
you're waking up on edge your cortisol
levels the stress hormone are the
highest first thing in the morning and
so when you wake up and you're already
at on edge feeling like oh my God how am
I going to get through the day how am I
going to pay my bills you're rattled
you're thinking you're worried your
cortisol levels are high that means
you're oh nervous system your alarm
system is already ringing so we gotta
flip the switch and turn off the alarm
before you start your day
so that your brain can focus and work
for you
so the way you're going to do this I
call this high-fiving your heart we're
going to press in the center of your
body and that's going to kind of right
by your heart it's going to press on
your vagus nerve that's where the on off
switch is and I'm going to teach you to
manually flip the switch
and to turn off the alarm system and to
turn on the calm grounded creative
nervous system that's going to help you
get back into a state of flow and help
you be more strategic because right now
is the most extraordinary moment in time
for you as a business owner I believe
and for a Creator so as you're pressing
right here you're just going to take a
deep breath
go ahead
and now I want you to say
these three sentences I'm okay
I'm okay I'm I'm safe
I'm safe
I'm loved
I am loved
that's it
and most mornings I need to do it about
23 times
I'm serious
like what happened but I just I love
that about you though like you're like
23 times like no exactly like
well you you know when it's I know when
you can stop because you actually have a
sensation
of the rattle shadowing and you come
back into your body
and I didn't realize until I learned
how to turn off the alarm and turn on
that cool rested state that my default
for as long as I can remember Chase has
been alarm mode
that I have been running so fast
mostly away from things
that I did not
comprehend
just how disregulated my nervous system
was and you know I think it's really
challenging for creatives like you and
me and everybody listening you know and
even if you're a small business owner
and you don't consider yourself a
creative and an artist your business is
your art
and as a you know small business owner
you're creating something
I didn't like slowing down is terrifying
when you're creative because there can
be this manic stressed out energy that's
part of the creative process
and so it was very foreign to me during
the pandemic to not be able to run
somewhere I mean I literally could not
go to get a cup of coffee or go to catch
a flight or run to Target to run an
errand which I didn't realize was how I
was kind of managing all of this
disregulated kind of survival mode
energy
but learning how to
stand in that frenzy put my hands on my
heart and bring myself back into my body
so that I could leverage the intense and
incredible power of my brain
and be strategic instead of reactive and
be confident instead of like chaotic
it's been life-changing and so I believe
that look you know Will putting your
hands on your heart take away your
problems no it won't change the
circumstances you're dealing with but
what it does is it changes you from the
inside out and changes your ability to
be calm and to be confident and to be
clear-minded and intentional about how
you face those things and that changes
everything
yeah everything because it happens it's
going to happen and it's not that we aim
to prevent things from happening but we
take control of our response to those
things right whether this is stoicism or
neurology or psychology all of those
things align to say that how we respond
is the measure of greatness right that
is how we become our best self I mean I
I give you an example Chase I so we just
we've been wrapping up kind of like this
big like book tour to the extent you can
do one in in these times and I went over
to London and we had an incredible you
know tour over in London and I took my
daughter with me and it was time to come
home
and
the regulations for getting
any kind of international travel at
least right now at the time that we are
filming this are mind-blowingly
complicated and they're changing in real
time and some involve printouts and
others involve apps and so I found
myself at 4 30 in the morning at the
airport
two days ago with my daughter and we
didn't have the right paperwork
and as soon as we learned we don't have
the right paperwork as soon as you start
to entertain I'm not getting out of this
country as soon as you learn that oh my
God am I going to have to quarantine
here for 14 days then can I get back in
the country oh my like and that whole
thing happens when you allow the stress
of your life or the stress of a moment
or the uncertainty of something or the
fear that you feel to all of a sudden
surge through your body you will not be
able to solve the problems you're facing
and so literally at 4 30 in the morning
at Heathrow I got my hands on my heart
as I'm huffing and puffing because I
didn't download the app and I can't get
back home and I don't want to stay here
for another 14 days and my daughter
started I'm I'm okay I'm safe I'm left
I'm okay I'm safe my daughter's like
what are you doing I'm like I'm okay I'm
safe I'm okay and I bring myself back
into my body and then I start saying
what if it all works out
what if everything's okay what if I
figure this out and I use the tools
to come back into the moment Chase
so that I can focus on what I need to do
and I'm telling you if you're a small
business owner and you are rattled and
you are living with sustained stress
it's hand to hand combat with yourself
in order to fight against the way that
your body your nervous system your
emotions can hijack you and you can get
control and the more you use the tools
that we're going to talk about the
faster and better you'll become at it
routine number three is run many days
with Ed mylett why is a day only 24
hours
I mean if the average people in the
world or the majority of people in the
world have a 24-hour day
why does that have to apply to you many
years ago I discovered have you ever had
a day where in four or five hours you
got more in the first four or five hours
done or accomplished in your day than
you had in a normal day you ever have a
four or five hour window a six hour
window like you go I've got so much done
in these six hours it's more of an I get
done in an average day and what I found
out was max out Elite performers people
that perform at the highest level they
get more done in a six hour window than
most people get done in a day and here's
why most people measure a day by 24
hours so I started to think I was young
in business I was in my early 20s and
one of the things that was held Against
Me by other people is you're too young
to win you don't have enough experience
you just haven't have enough days of
experience in your life enough days in
business to win I thought well how can I
fix that and here's how you can fix that
and I've adopted this now for almost 30
years
I want the average people I compete
against to think they have a 24-hour day
my days are six days long
so I want to teach you the concept of
running many days
my day my first day is from 6 a.m to
noon every day that's a full day for me
so I try to get done a full day's work
from 6 a.m to noon because I no longer
have a 24-hour day of my life I have a
six hour day and so a day to me is that
measure of time it altered the complete
direction of my life it transformed who
I am so now from 6am to noon is a day
that's my first day
every single week 6 a.m to noon Monday
morning and what happens in that 6 a.m
to noon I see there's a mental thing we
have I have a whole day to get all these
things done and so we stack and dictate
and schedule our day over that 24-hour
window of time you'd be surprised if you
shrunk it eight to six hours you can get
the same things done in those six hours
you used to get done in 24. from noon to
6 p.m is my second day and in that
second day I fill it up with the with a
full day's worth of fun memories
meetings phone calls you name it
meetings with my relationships in my
life in that six hour day I pack out
another day from noon to 6 p.m I fill
that day up and my third day is 6 p.m to
midnight and then at 6 p.m to midnight
same thing my relationships my meetings
my phone calls my emails the work I do
is a third day and so what happened was
when I was in my early 20s I went from
having three days in the same window of
time when the average person had one and
I started to accomplish triple what the
average person was accomplishing now
once again you stack up three days and
24 hours over a week a month a year in
just one year I end up with over a
thousand days and I'm competing against
people only have 365. think about the
mind-blowing difference could be in your
life if you ran many days the rest of
your life I'm telling you right now that
my days are six hours long you'll be the
the amount of work you could get done
the amount of compounding that will take
place in your life it's gonna blow your
mind when you start looking at your
schedule day one is six a.m to noon day
two is noon to 6 p.m day 3 is 6 p.m to
midnight your whole existence is going
to change and it'll be kind of fun in
the beginning you'll mess it up but you
stack up a week or two and you do that
for a month imagine that in one month
getting 90 days
think about what would happen in your
life within a month you had 90 days and
the rest of the world the average in
your life imagine that for a second the
rest of the world only had 30. and you
stacked that up over a year or three
years how different would your life be
and I'm telling you I'm an example of
how different your life would be
I'm an example of what that productivity
and compounding in your life can look
like more fun more memories more
meetings more encounters more
relationships more experiences More
Money More achievement more joy more
bliss I'm creating opportunities
constantly so what I do is I shrink the
finish line so there's Sprints all the
time and so because I only have a six
hour day I'm in a hurry throughout that
day I'm not jogging I'm not walking I'm
in a big hurry and you're going to be
amazed at the transformation you're like
I may never give you a bigger gift
than the concept of six hour days I
think I'm one of the only people you'll
ever hear explain this to you but I can
tell you I started to study these
successful mentors in my mind my gosh
they get so much done before nine
o'clock in the morning my gosh by one
o'clock they've accomplished so much and
the average person is just stretching
getting out of bed done their first
appointment or two especially you
entrepreneurs out there how critical
this is because when you're an employee
at least as an employee to some extent
they control your time they dictate you
need to be here at 9 00 a.m you can't
leave until 5 PM and so although that's
a that's a nuisance it helps you be more
productive because they're paying you
they tell you when to be there but what
happens for most entrepreneurs they
don't realize when you become an
entrepreneur you've taken on three jobs
four jobs it requires more time but
people start to relax ah my time's mine
my time's free I love the freedom of
being an entrepreneur there's the
greatest fallacy in the world is that
you are free as an entrepreneur as a
matter of fact you have more
responsibility more obligations more
accountability when you're an
entrepreneur because there's no
guaranteed money coming in the the
biggest mistake the biggest misnomer the
worst thinking you could have as an
entrepreneur is that somehow you're free
because you don't have a job just
because you call yourself an
entrepreneur if you are one doesn't make
you free a fact that makes you less free
and so what will make you free is really
being free really getting financially
independent really having enough money
that you would never need to work again
really having enough money that if you
didn't want to take a meeting you didn't
have to so stop deluding yourself into
this false sense of freedom because you
call yourself an entrepreneur it's
hilarious and it's why you're losing you
have this fallacy this relaxed state of
Freedom where you're going to get around
to doing things and you get to go to the
gym anytime you want to and you're
wearing your sweats at 10 30 in the
morning right you wouldn't do that if
you work for someone else you don't do
that when you work for you and so the
greatest thing I could give you is the
gift of many days also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
routine number four is work on one idea
per day with Bob Proctor what you're
watching here is going to be a very very
short with video so I'm going to ask you
to bring your will to bear and focus
really focus on this idea because it's
an idea that can change your life it
certainly changed mine people are always
asking me in seminars Bob how do you
schedule your day and you know that's
not an easy answer for me because every
day is different with me I do a lot of
different things but there is one
constant it's how you start your day
Earl Nightingale taught me that a long
long time ago he said Bob is not how you
spend your days it's how you start your
day you start your day off right and
everything is going to work in your
favor and you put seven of them together
and you've got a very successful week so
he said pick a good idea well you know I
have a book here how to sell yourself to
others by Elmer wheeler Elmer wheeler
was one of America's greatest
salespeople so I use that and I just
open it here what we call manners that's
an idea what we call manners if I
manually all day long if I keep that in
mind I want to be mannerly with
everybody all day long that's going to
help me so I take an idea like that
every morning and I write it down I put
in a piece of paper carry it in my
pocket and that's an idea I'm going to
work on all day long if something goes a
little wrong I work on that idea I take
that idea you do this and you're going
to win routine number five is boost your
confidence with Dean graziosi who in
here has got a morning routine
awesome amazing
there's a morning routine that I have
that I think is I'm just going to use
mine as an example and you can modify
yours any way you want and you probably
got one better than me if you're doing
it but here's what I know I want you to
think of a morning routine differently
think of it as if I do my morning
routine right
I set my day up for confidence
and when you have confidence think of
this as at least the stuff I think you
play offense all day rather than playing
defense
have you ever had a day or many days
where you wake up and you're just
waiting for the wrong emails waiting for
the phone call waiting to talk to your
spouse waiting to talk to the guys you
work with or girls you work with waiting
to talk to the boss waiting to talk to
your employers like you're you're kind
of just putting out fires like you're
standing waiting for the crap to go
wrong except compared to the days you're
like this is my day I got this [ __ ] yeah
we do this let's do this right one is
offense one is defense one is 100
confidence one's like 97 confidence so
how do you how do you create hacks and
little things in your life that aren't
like I like to do stuff that's little
shifts if we if I came in here and said
meditate for one hour work out for two
hours then go practice gratitude and
then Envision where you'll be it's like
all right that's 11 o'clock I'm at work
by eight let's get come on D let's be
real so I want to give you real stuff so
if you think about setting your
confidence up and you think about
playing a day with offense then I want
to set that up in the morning so for me
here's what I I'd suggest
who in here has has their phone next to
them
be honest when they sleep
Okay who in here one of the first things
you do when you roll over in the morning
is grab your phone
yeah so here's what I know if something
great comes through your phone awesome
but how many times have you ever rolled
over and looked at your phone going ah
or or check a Facebook and say nobody
liked that picture I thought that I
looked really good in that
I took 72 of them and put 14 filters on
it why is there no likes on that
but think about it is that setting your
day up for offense or defense
defense so here's a suggestion I got
this from Ariana Huffington
put your phone on airplane mode before
you go to bed
and do not check it as soon as you wake
up
maybe 20 of the time there's something
good the person you love says I love you
you're amazing have a perfect day
you hope that's what comes through but
usually it's like the deal fell flat
we're screwed no I'm kidding
um so put your phone on airplane mode
you then what I've what I do because I
have like a nine minute routine I also
have a half hour routine my nine minute
routine as soon as I open my eyes is I
try to think of and we all know this I'm
gonna say something that you never heard
before try to be grateful but here's
what I've done I've lowered the bar of
gratitude everybody in this room has
accomplished so much that sometimes we
set the bar so high with gratitude we
don't realize it like we're look we're
searching for gratitude like how did
everything spectacular happen how did
the moon the stars part or the the
clouds part and I saw like no like wake
up and realize 150 000 people die every
day today 150 000 tomorrow yesterday
you woke up sometimes I wake up and go
wow these sheets feel amazing
God this is a comfy pillow like just
find something and all you guys is just
trick in your brain to be grateful in
the moment not a big long gratitude
process and I'd love I love to meditate
and meditating more than I ever had I'm
just talking about your first thoughts
and if you if you have troubles with
that then grab a book that you love
you know there's a couple habits books
out that are really awesome right now
it's just like high performance habits
millionaire success habits there's some
great habits books I'm just saying no
but grab a book that you love or the
Bible whatever fills your soul and just
read three sentences just so your mind
is opening up the moment you open up
you're filling it with gratitude you're
filling it with appreciation you're
feeling filling it with personal growth
right so the way I look at it is I
protect myself offensively by leaving my
phone on airplane mode don't check it
yet
I do a couple minutes of either low
level gratitude or I'll literally I love
the untethered soul I love a lot you
know I love a lot of books but the
untethered soul for me I could open up
any page read two sentences and get
something from it right so I'll either
read that and then as soon as I do that
I just immediately think of some
intention for the day now guys this is
literally all in minutes I'll think what
do I want to accomplish today what would
make me feel good uh today literally
this morning I woke up I said today I
want to live the experience with this
crowd I don't want to go up and try to
remember what to say I just want to be
present I want to serve I want to give
all of me on the stage all I thought
about for three and a half minutes maybe
more like 30 seconds but three and a
half minutes I did gratitude thought
about my day in the wins so for me is I
protected myself defensively offensively
then I filled my soul that's what I feel
right so then I get up and then I feel
like I want to feed my body so for me I
makes me more confident feels better
about myself I do a green drink in the
morning first thing soon as I wake up I
go downstairs I I put a scoop of green
powder water I squeeze a lemon put some
apple cider vinegar some MCT oil and I
down it so then I feel like I fed my
soul I fed my you know my body and then
I go move
and for me it's like I have to exercise
the morning I don't know whoever
exercises in the afternoon or evenings I
give you all the props in the world but
when my mind gets going man I can't stop
I don't want to go to the gym I always
lie to myself if I say I'm gonna go in
the afternoon I never do then I feel
guilty so for me I got to get up get
right out of bed feed my soul feed my
body and then I go move whether that's
for me it's going to the gym or going to
do spin or hike Camelback Mountain but
if you're if it's moving just walk
outside take a walk take a run do
something and in that time in that time
uh that you do that
in the time that you do that you are
setting up the confidence and routine
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is start with
gratitude with Jay Shetty every morning
I wake up at 6am after eight hours of
sleep and I say to myself I'm so
grateful for today I don't look at my
phone for the first two hours I don't
want to be externally stimulated I want
to be internally situated I brush my
teeth first thing and practice mindful
brushing bringing my awareness to one
side at a time one tooth at a time one
brush at a time so I always always
always want to start my day with
gratitude now gratitude isn't just some
fluffy concept it's actually been proven
by science to reduce physical aches and
pains so it's great for your physical
health but even more than that gratitude
is incredible for our psychological and
mental health it removes these toxic
emotions of envy a resentment of
bitterness and actually has been shown
to increase happiness and decrease
depression so you want to start your day
with gratitude you want to make your
first thought a grateful thought so that
then you can be grateful throughout the
rest of the day meditation my two-hour
practice has been part of my life for 13
years it includes breath work
visualization and Mantra meditation so
don't worry I didn't always used to
meditate for two hours a day it's a
practice that I've developed over the
last 13 years and one of the biggest
reasons is I feel it gives me a strong
foundation so just as our body needs to
eat every day just as our body needs to
move every day our mind needs to eat and
move and be fueled so a lot of
activities we do throughout the day
whether it's watching a TV show or
whether it's entertaining ourselves is
actually using the mind not refueling
the mind but meditation is a brilliant
practice again scientifically proven to
actually give the mind the nutrients and
the focus that it needs to perform at
its best I then usually step outside to
get some fresh air I eat some porridge
or oatmeal and I eat the same thing
every day so that my system is familiar
and focused I then step outside to look
into the distance it's good for our
eyesight because we're usually looking
at our phones so close every day
you want me there so this is how most of
us spend our days looking at a nearby
object our phone screens is what we're
glued to every single moment that's why
getting outdoors and looking into the
distance for five to ten minutes a day
actually improves our eyesight and the
thing I love it about the most is that
actually what we're doing externally
affects us internally let me explain
when we spend our lives getting stuck
into the detail we're so lost in the
in-between we're lost in this small
picture these small ideas these small
issues we don't have a look at the big
picture so when you start going Outdoors
for five to ten minutes a day looking
into the distance looking at the big
picture you start to do that internally
too rather than getting caught in the
bits and pieces of Our Lives we start
looking at the bigger lens the big
escape and this is a great way to get
started I check my phone at 8 15 am for
the first time when walking down to the
gym I get a couple of minutes of social
media and email before my my personal
trainer takes over my life the gym has
always been less about how I look and
more about how I feel 45 minute workouts
four to five days a week a great way of
staying active mobile and healthy oh am
I trying to throws in a little boxing
never against anyone don't worry no one
gets hurt I've always been competitive
and loved sport boxing allows me to
focus on the target use more energy and
get the cardio in without having to go
for a run
oh
and that's how I get set for the day
five days a week and in the words of
Muhammad Ali that's how I don't count
the days but make the days count
you need someone who you can trust like
if you're giving someone your money like
or you're trying to take someone's
advice or counsel you need to trust
their intentions all right and so it's
not just whether they have integrity
it's whether they have your best
interest in mind all right so I'm going
to get to how I solve for that in a
second but if that is the first
character trait of you need that you
need of a council of somebody of any
kind of council really whether it's
investment law Etc the second
um is efficacy or their skill set right
so let's think of both let's think of
just different scenarios here so let's
say you might trust your mom implicitly
but she doesn't have the skill of
knowing much about you know how to
structure insurance policies or trusts
or you know investments in Tech startups
right you might not have that skill but
you might trust her intention right for
you specifically on the reverse of that
you might see that there's this person
who's got lots of skill is prodigious in
this but it also means that they know
exactly how to screw you if they want to
right which is one of the double-sided
things of being really good at something
right you know all the details you know
how to write the agreement structure the
deals in order to make sure that you you
know get the best outcome right and so
the idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counsel from I have to look at these two
things all right so here here's how I
test for the Integrity piece and here's
how you can kind of like you can control
for risk here right one is I always try
and interview as many advisors as
humanly possible all right and I do that
because I'm going to get as much
information from each of the council
during this process that will give me
perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks this 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the Integrity
piece is that I try and have a line
incentives now a lot of times there are
incentive systems that appear aligned
but not are not in reality so let me
give you an example so in the real
estate market if you're a realtor for
example you may think oh this realtor
has my best interest at heart right
because they have an incentive to sell
the house and so that is why they're
going to get compensated so they want to
sell it for as much as possible ah but
they aren't incentivized to sell it for
as much as possible they're incentivized
to sell it as fast as possible and get a
deal closed all right and so think about
this for you selling a house for five
hundred thousand dollars that's worth
five hundred thousand dollars is a
normal you know that like that's normal
that's the market price right but for
you to make an extra let's say twenty
five thousand or fifty thousand dollars
would be really material that would be a
huge extra outcome for you you would
probably push a lot harder to get the
extra 25 or 50 000 now let's say that um
you could probably sell it in a day at
450 000 because it's below the market
value of the house right now here's
what's crazy is that if a a selling
realtor you know like total it might be
seven percent two percent goes to the
buyer and five percent goes to the
seller if five percent is going to your
realtor five percent of five hundred
thousand dollars right is 25 Grand okay
and so for them the the fifty thousand
dollar decrease to drop you from 500 to
450 means that they're going to give up
2500 so they're gonna make twenty two
thousand five hundred so let me ask you
a question now in the reverse if they
sell for 525 they're going to get 27 500
right and so it's a 5 000 swing off of a
you know 25 000 nut for them and one of
them might take them three months and
one of them might take them a day so
what is their incentive
their incentive is to get the is to make
as much money as possible per unit of
time and so their incentivized to sell
as fast as possible and so this is one
of those things where you have to put
your thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when I say there's
two aspects that I look for Council or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally Insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
Integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're going to get
zero percent on anything below four
hundred thousand dollars I'll give you
three percent on anything between 400
and 450 and then from 450 and up I'll
give you 20 right or 15 or whatever
right and so now they're highly
incentivized to push and now your
incentives are aligned because each
increment for you is worth almost as
much it is to them and that is how you
would align incentives all right now how
do you test for the second thing which
is their skill set
this one's hard all right especially if
you don't have the perspective from
which to make a judgment which when I
answer new things when I'm trying to
learn about trust and I'm trying to
learn about investment things and
different Vehicles I'm learning about
storage units more about multi like
you're like oh man there's so much stuff
and there's so much Nuance that you have
to have right and so the first thing is
I like to usually read two to three
books on the topic all right and I read
two to three books just so I don't
appear like an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're going to
respect you to they will it's kind of
like defense if you bring your if you
bring at least some level of knowledge
they don't feel like they're going to
take advantage of you so this is this is
the first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try and talk as to
as many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that that
buys X Y and Z right or you'd or you
have somebody who who manages your
portfolio whatever it is right that one
decision can be one of the most if not
the biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my my investments I
know she has my best at heart but she
has no idea what she's doing and then I
don't want somebody who absolutely knows
what they're doing and does not have my
best interest at heart right which
honestly unfortunately is a lot more of
the cases that that you'll come up with
and candidly you know a lot of times
they're literally incentivized against
you you know uh in the insurance
industry they're they're kind of
incentivized to rip you off it's it's
it's pretty terrible and there's a lot
of Industries like that mortgage brokers
are incentivized to rip you off and so
you really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with if
you have friends that make you wrong for
changing your life for the better that's
their issue it's not yours and so you
gotta untangle the fact that they have
baggage about getting in shape or they
have baggage about going to the bar
that's theirs and it has nothing to do
with the decisions that you're making so
if you're friends in general give you
blowback for changing for the better
what you need to say in the back your
mind is interesting they're obviously
very conflicted about their choice to go
to the bar and drink every night but
that has nothing to do with me here's
the other thing you can do if they start
to make you wrong you can say well you
want to go to Planet Fitness with me
instead it doesn't sound like you want
to be at the bar so that said let me
talk to you a little bit about friends
friends are people that you care about
and I have this test I call it the
funeral test if somebody in your life
were to die ask yourself would I go to
their funeral if the answer is yes
they're a friend of yours that's the
test for whether or not in my opinion
someone is a friend because it means you
care about them now here's the other
thing about friendship that I want you
to understand you can care about
somebody and not like hanging out with
them and that's the situation that
you're in right now that you have plenty
of friends that you care about if they
were to die you would go to their
funeral if they needed you you would be
there if you saw them you'd be happy to
see them but you don't like to hang out
with them the other thing that I want
you to think about is is that and that's
okay that's like a normal part of
friendship and the reason why that's a
normal part of friendship is because one
of the things that we know about life is
that you're always going to be changing
in the old pattern and the old chapter
you had certain patterns right in the
old chapter of your life you would go to
the bar and drink you would go to the
store and spend money you didn't have
you're in a new chapter now and so you
have different patterns when your life
takes on different patterns whether it's
you're no longer going to the bar you're
going to the gym the pattern might even
be that one of your kids is playing with
a different soccer team or maybe you've
moved to a different street in your town
when the patterns change so will your
circle of friends it's a fact of life
but that doesn't mean your old friends
the ones that you used to drink with
aren't friends anymore it just means
that you don't want to hang out with
them you still care about them but you
don't like doing what they do the
patterns have changed for a long time I
had a lot of drama around this until I
realized that it's not personal it's not
personal that you don't want to hang out
with them patterns in your life have
simply changed the final thing that I'm
going to that may also help you is that
remember I've given you the funeral test
if you'd go to their funeral they're
definitely a friend it means you care
about them but you might not like
hanging out with them that much and
that's cool that's normal the other
thing that I want you to think about
when it comes to friendships is you can
typically put friends into three buckets
you got friends for a reason you got
friends for a season and you have
friends for a lifetime and one of the
interesting things that I know about my
own life is that as the patterns of my
life change so do the friends that I
hang out with more frequently and I also
believe that as you change and the
patterns in your life change people show
up in your life for a reason the right
people will show up when you start going
to the gym the right people that you
need for the pattern that you're in
right now will start showing up when
you're working on your project instead
of shopping and it's exactly the kind of
people that you need they're there for a
reason and the friends of yours that are
friends of yours for a lifetime I bet
you don't hang out with them that much
at all anyway but I bet they're the
first person to that you call when you
need to talk to somebody about somebody
important those are the friends for a
lifetime and those folks that are still
sitting at the bar and love to blow
money that they don't have those were
friends for a season you have to be all
in and it's the hardest thing to do
because if it fails then you can feel
like a failure
um you know I think of this idea of
performance necessity two stories kind
of come to mind one is I was working
with an Olympic gold medal is Sprinter
and we're in the tunnel and we're going
out and he's talking about the
competition and we get out to the blocks
and I said uh he was really worried
about the competition I said well how do
you even gauge like who who who's going
to win
you know in in his particular race
people are winning but by you know one
one hundredths of a second tenths of
seconds I mean these are really close
Sprints and I said well how how do you
know I said who would you even bet on
and he says you know I would bet on the
guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line then says
I gotta do this
for my mom
and I was like oh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is it's necessary for him to win
that race for his mom
um I think of you know when I started
my career and I I really decided to go
all in with writing and online training
um this is like 2000 probably six uh I'd
gone broke completely bankrupt and
failed I left my corporate job I had
this cushy kind of corporate job as a
consultant good job
um left it to write and I didn't know
how to make it as a writer I want to do
seminars workshops didn't know how to do
that so I was pretty much a hot mess ran
out of money
um I got nothing to my name nothing kind
of no positive prospects no one's
calling me except the guys who want the
money and um
one night I'm writing and the
apartment's so small on the bed I had a
all you know what my bills my vision
boards all my research all my journals
like the bed was basically the desk the
extended desk and my lady comes in
Denise and she walks past me but she
sees I'm like trying to write so it
doesn't want to disturb me she goes
crawls under
um the covers of the bed
and I'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and I look over
and
I see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know because none of us want to see
our you know
our family suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
I was just like
figure this out
and I'm telling you I wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day I wrote more than ever that
birth life's golden ticket which became
a bestseller and in you know 18 months
later because I was like I'm gonna
figure out this online thing I mean
throughout marketing I'm gonna figure
out how to teach I'm gonna how to train
and get paid for it because I've never
really been paid for those things I said
I'm gonna figure out this industry and
I'm gonna make it 18 months later after
her
crawling under the bills I made 4.6
million dollars Jesus online
Total Transformation people like how did
you do it I'm like she gave me and she
was my necessity I was not going to let
my woman be in that situation
um and she believed in me she supported
me she married me and uh you know but
that was she was my drive
and the second part was I went all in
with my identity I said I am going to be
a great writer
and I am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said an intro now we've
graduated over 2 million people have
taken our online courses video series
now I don't think it would have happened
if I hadn't had the guts and maybe
the no other choice right to say this is
who I'm going to be and I'm going to
build into that
and it's necessary for me to become that
person so let's go you wanted to be a
professional baseball player yeah right
yeah but then you got an injury I did
similar to me so you never made it to
the big league so did you play minor
league I did yeah and I played division
one college baseball too yeah I like
every guy like you and I talked about
this last time it's always our injuries
that ended our careers I probably it
probably put me into a premature place
where I was going anyways you aren't
going to be in The Bigs for I wasn't I
played enough baseball with guys who
ended up in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me it certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah I want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended your identity was like who
am I right yes lost yeah like a lot you
and I were just talking before we went
on yeah you know our professional
athlete friends were there rare changes
I went into a like anybody like whatever
your dream is when the first one ends it
doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage
it ends it was a dream right or a
business venture or a sport I went into
a pretty good depression and uh and how
old were you at the time 21 22 and I
ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever houses or whatever the material
things are but I ended up bad man I
ended up to press I ended up moving back
at home with my parents I was living in
the city I remember I was living in this
sleeping in the same bed I grew up in
with the same teddy bear the same
posters I was like going back in time
like six years on back where I was
totally unemployed and uh couldn't find
work didn't have the motivation to get
up and find a job just sort of eating
out of their fridge and laying around
all day so that's where I was many many
years ago after baseball and when you
realize things in your life happen for
you truly especially in hindsight
everybody knows it in hindsight right if
you look back at any disaster tragedy
most people look back five ten years
they think that happened for me that was
actually a good thing and so I was
unemployed I couldn't find a job and my
old man my dad was the best dad role
model he could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked out I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm at mylette I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh yeah we know that too and so
they bring me to the guy and he says uh
you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became on this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like McKinley is a massive
campus full of children that have been
displaced from their homes that live in
individual like Cottages like a foster
care facility massive though really yeah
all boys it's in San Dimas here and wow
it just altered my life man because I
I'd been an athlete had a huge ego had
that mask I wanted to compete I wanted
to win I wanted attention I wanted
recognition first time literally in my
life I went well I I love helping people
I love making a difference and my boys
were just come from horrendous
situations and so just I always say this
all the time and I have those eyes too
you have them I think sometimes kids who
grow up with some dysfunction they just
have different eyes yeah they just have
these eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they just like man love me believe in me
you know care about me and I had those
eyes because I grew up in an alcoholic
family and my whole life changed I just
went wow I love I actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives I didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about
me it was about these 10 boys that ended
up being 10 of them and it just altered
my life man and so after that I ran into
the financial business that I ended up
in but I would have completely flunked
out of that Financial business had I not
been with my boys for those years and I
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I
think about I'm not kidding you I think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where I
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what I wanted to do I always wanted
to be famous and Rich and successful and
now I just wanted to serve yeah I wanted
to help the little that I find out I
could get rich and famous and all that
other stuff I thought I wanted through
serving people the most important part
of a morning routine is how you feel
about yourself it's the number one thing
that people do not pay attention to that
matters the most is how do you feel
about yourself when you're done your
morning routine nobody wakes up perfect
nobody wakes up full of energy yes ready
to go wrong I can't believe today is
another day or what a day to be alive
I'm so grateful I like nobody nobody Mel
Robbins Evan Carmichael Tony Robbins
nobody
the difference between where most people
are at and the people who have success
is that they demand
that they show up and they create that
through the routines and the habits
which is your morning routines the
easiest way to just get started so you
go from being tired and having stuff in
your eyes and lines on your face and
rolling out of bed to then feeling
inspired motivated ready to take on the
day
how do you do that well
you have to find the thing that actually
makes you feel powerful inspired
motivated confident and ready to go and
most people
just go through the motions and I'm
talking to the Achievers now most of
America most of the world doesn't have a
morning routine at all they fall into
their day they wake up like an accident
and they start falling into what other
people want them to do for the day like
most people wake up and just immediately
go to their phones see the crisis and
they're rushing off to go work on
somebody else's dream they wake up drop
the job that they hate to work on
building somebody else's dream that's
most people you guys watching this
you're probably more on the achiever
side you probably have some kind of
morning routine you're probably doing
more than your friends and the people
around you
the challenge with Achievers and the
morning routine is most of the time
you're going through the motions to just
check the box and feel like I got it
done as opposed to actually getting the
feeling the most important part of a
morning routine is the feeling
so I had on my tour I had a woman
in Albuquerque New Mexico
talk about morning routines and she
asked me what mine was and I told her
what mine was but mine doesn't matter
what matters is what you're doing and so
I asked her what what do you do in your
morning routine well the first thing I
do every day is I pray
great so you pray and let me be let me
ask you an honest question
I need you to be honest right now it's
important for me for you for everybody
here
how many times when you're doing the
prayer when you've done the same prayer
so many times
when you when you're going through the
prayers how many times are you just
saying the words because you know the
words you've memorized them you say them
a million times
how many times you've just seen the
words
and how many times you actually feel
the Deep connection how many times you
actually feel the power flowing through
you
and I figure what the number was it says
40 something like what she actually
feels the power like that's the problem
that's the problem with achievers
you are going through the motions of
your morning routine without without
ever having a Feeling
so that you finish him want to routine
whether it's 10 minutes an hour four
hours however long your morning routine
needs to be
if you don't feel confident alive bold
powerful at the end of your morning
routine then your morning routine isn't
working
I don't care that you check the box of
having done your prayers or watched that
video the number of people who watch a
video but then you're doing it while
you're making your bread or brushing
your teeth or eating breakfast or
whatever you're not ever really
intentional about watching the video
that's great that you can check the box
of saying you watch your video but you
didn't get the feeling so it doesn't
matter if you don't feel more bold
powerful confident ready to take on the
day at the end of the morning routine
then your morning routine is broken and
needs to be fixed and it's either adding
something new in
that actually makes you feel that way or
just doing the thing that you already
know works but with more intention
so that's what the woman needs to do is
go back and fix some more routine just
with more intention
we often compare ourselves to other
people and their morning routines the
morning routine envy and say Well
they're doing it so I should be doing it
like that I should be working out like
the rock four hours a day that's
probably not what you want to be doing
the key is figuring out what makes you
happy what is the life that you want to
live understand that your routines
really are set up for you to have the
habits to follow through on success that
you're looking for right success is
habit success is what you do on a daily
basis and your morning routine sets you
up for that so how do we actually then
create a morning routine that works all
right let me let me get practical move
from just inspiring to some tips that
you can actually go off and accomplish
step number one the most important thing
what makes you feel the belief in
yourself
of all the things that you do
that you've tried that you've done what
makes you feel the most belief in
yourself maybe it's watching a video
like this is why I design these videos
to try to be a part of your morning
routine I'm I'm honored for anybody who
is is using these videos uh as that so
thank you but whether it's these videos
whether it's reading the book whether
it's meditation prayer working out
getting in nature petting your cats like
what is the thing that makes you feel
belief in yourself
that you're capable of more that today
can be a great day because you're not
don't have the expectations of you
waking up feeling great you won't you're
going to wake up like yes
but what is the thing that you do the
most that has led to you feeling that
love of belief
and you can string together a couple
like when I do this and this and this
and this great
this becomes a seed of your morning
routine
so make that list step number two
is there a sequence to them
what what's the one thing that when you
just start doing that thing it
kick-starts everything else
foreign so that's why making the bed is
is something for a lot of people it's
not that making the bed actually gets
you feel motivated it's that you're the
kind of person who makes the bed and
then it's what happens next is that when
you make the bed you're more likely to
then do the next thing
you're picking something simple as the
first step not because of it actually
doing anything to make you feel great is
that it
makes you do the next step and the next
step and the next step so making your
bread brushing your teeth flossing your
teeth like whatever the thing is
what's the easiest part of the routine
because working out for example working
notes on your list that's hard
you might have lots of energy and
excitement now but tomorrow morning
you're going to wake up and not want to
work out even though you know logically
you know that working out will get you
feeling
not expired inspired
hopefully not expired inspired motivated
for the day you feel great after a
workout you don't want to do the work in
the morning
so don't make workout your first thing
something easier that you can fall into
so making the bed
brushing your teeth or if there's
something else drinking a glass of water
like you're the kind of person who
drinks a glass of water in the morning
so then you follow through on the next
thing and the next and the next thing so
you start stacking them
right so step number one is you make a
list of the things that make you feel
the belief the courage and motivation
the fire and you you put that into
routine but step number two is now we're
going to order them and figure it out
what is the easiest best place for me to
get started on these things
so that I can still follow through on
everything else that when I do that one
thing everything else Cascades in order
and then step number three is just make
it realistic
make it realistic you can actually do it
one of the biggest problems that people
have with morning routines
is you create this perfect morning
routine that takes you four hours to do
and there's unrealistic for you to
actually follow through on you'll do it
for two days and then realize wow this
is
this is just not happening I'm not I'm
not doing it and what that translates
often is then therefore you suck because
you can't follow the routine therefore
you suck and then the whole day gets
thrown away and the next day and the
next day the next week the next month
nothing ends up happening until you get
inspired for a new morning routine right
so the point of trying on other people's
morning routines or getting some ideas
is really just to figure out what works
for you
for example
uh the whole idea of writing in a
journal
journaling just doesn't do it for me
I've tried it a whole bunch of times I
used to feel bad about myself the
journaling didn't work like why doesn't
work for me what's wrong with me why why
don't I feel better after journaling my
hand gets tired I can't read my own
handwriting I don't know it doesn't
doesn't do anything for me so
after hearing how for how many people at
work the work the work the work okay I
can wait I'm gonna I'm gonna do
morning pages and I started writing
whatever comes my mind and if I didn't
know what to write I would write I don't
know what to write I'm just reading what
comes to my mind and having the freedom
just to write that stuff down
but after evaluating I realized this
I feel no better coming out of this
morning routine than I did going in
and if that's the result for you it
doesn't matter that Evan Carmichael does
it or Mel Robbins does it or garyvee
does it or whoever does it it's not
working for you great you can tweak it
test it again try something different
and if it's still not working for you
abandon it and go do something else and
don't feel bad that it's not working for
you
it's fantastic go find a thing that is
just because somebody else is doing it
doesn't mean that it's going to work for
you just because that hat fits
beautifully in somebody else doesn't
mean that it's going to work for you
maybe you shouldn't wear hats ever
right
so step one go back to figuring out what
are all the things that you love doing
that make you feel bold confident a lot
the goal of your morning routine again
is to make you feel bold powerful
confident alive ready to take on the day
two you sequence them to figure out
what's the order
so how can you start with the easiest
thing that when you do that thing
everything else Falls in place and then
three make it realistic
make it realistic that is something that
you can stick to that you can do that
will fit into your life it doesn't
require superhuman effort to wake up and
do every day that if you're traveling or
something ends up happening you can
mostly stay consistent on it right make
it realistic for your life and what
you're doing because when you can start
your day
with the expectation of not having
energy
right you don't put the fake expectation
of you having to wake up tons of with
tons of energy
but then creating a structure for
yourself
that will bring the energy forward
if you can imagine for the next year
wake up have no energy do something that
will give you energy to show up more
confidently in your life for the day
ahead
imagine how much of a change that will
make in your life if you spent a year
doing that waking up little energy
waking up like you normally do
and then after your routine
after doing a couple things whatever
they are for you being bold powerful
confident alive how does your whole life
change how does your business change how
does your career change how do
relationships change all of it because
you chose to show up with intention by
following those three simple steps
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want five one routines it will transform
your life check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there all right let's be honest how many
of y'all get up and you just get your
day started you don't have it written
down you don't have a strategy you don't
have a real plan you kind of just get up
and say I'm about to tackle today raise
your hand for me raise your hand we're
gonna stop no more of that